[Musique]
le président du département cyrille
melchior s'est rendu au collège de
l'étang à saint-paul ce vendredi 5
octobre pour participer à la plantation
d'une trentaine d'espèces endémiques et
indigènes dans l'établissement ce projet
passe et s'inscrire dans le
développement durable comme on l'a fait
au niveau du collège depuis longtemps
c'est exploiter un terrain qui était
voilà un petit peu non utilisés pour
justement a emmené la préservation des
espèces la connaissance aussi des
espèces pour les élèves parce que là
aujourd'hui plantes les élèves mais ils
vont venir voir ces espèces comprendre
d'où elles viennent comment aussi elle
pousse comment elles se reproduisent
et voilà pour le président du
département cette action est une
démarche nécessaire compte tenu des
défis climatiques énergétique et
écologique à relever pour protéger la
planète
c'est un magnifique projet vous savez
quand on voit des enfants
planter des arbres ça ne peut que nous
réjouir parce qu'on pense bien sûr
développement durable on pense éducation
on pense promotion de l'environnement
est dans une période où
nous devons penser vraiment à préserver
les espaces naturels de la réunion les
arbres endémiques et bien je suis fier
de voir que le collège de l'étang sur le
principal et l'ensemble des équipes
pédagogiques qui l'entourent ont initié
ce beau projet d'arboretum grâce à cet
arboretum les élèves pourront suivre et
étudier la croissance de ces espèces
tout au long de leur scolarité
aujourd'hui en fait on planque désole
pour le collège de l'étang 300 ans avant
tout on fait ça pour auprès bombe
pourrait tout à fait l'écologie tout ça
l'enclos un peu de watts bonnet beau
jude à détendre mais aussi la voilà ce
couple entre tient bien planté janot
et ça me fait plaisir et
hecquet
les fidjiens et regarder tout l'été le
faire du travail et être ensemble
tc plessé afin au lieu de travailler en
détruit que six bien six dvd ne me
souviens amara avoir un beau jardin pour
le collège début 2019 en ruche et
pédagogie deviendra trouver sa place
dans l'établissement
[Musique]